Google Apps Script is a cloud based development
platform for creating web applications.
With just a browser you can build scalable
web applications that integrate easily with
Google products.
Apps Script uses a familiar JavaScript format,
so you can take what you know about web development
and what you know about Google products and
create something new really quick.
Google APIs and user interface tools are built
right into Apps Script as Services and the
Script Editor give you fast access to all
the services with code completion.
Accustomed to editing HTML?
There’s an HTML Service you can use to make
templates and layouts.
switch to GUI controls Or, if you’ve used
the Google Web Toolkit, you’ll recognize
the controls and layout panels available to
create robust interfaces.
And, with the same library of Services you
can save data in Google Spreadsheets, connect
to external databases, or use the new ScriptDb
to create a JavaScript object store.
When you’re ready to share your web application,
publish it as its own service with versioning
and sharable libraries.
Apps Script even has quick publishing to the
Chrome Web Store, where anyone can find, install,
and use your web application.
To create a new script project of your own,
open Google Drive, and click Create, more,
Script.
Or, just go to script.google.com to start
your first project today.